ex chanteur du groupe baobab il a créé
en parallèle à sa carrière solo un
spectacle jeune public intitulé au fond
de la classe qu'il présentera notamment
le 4 juin au scarabée à La Verrière un
spectacle qui séduit les parents comme
les enfants et donc il va nous parler
tout de suite voici Merlot dans le
kiosque et tu me rends mon cartable
rends-moi mon cartable
au fond de la classe j'ai enlevé mes
godasses j'ai mis mes chaussons je suis
comme à la maison
une proposition qu'on m'a fait quelqu'un
qui travaillait chez Milan et qui avait
une collection qui s'appelle Tintin elle
m'a demandé de choisir un thème
rapidement elle avait très peu de temps
donc j'ai dû faire ce disque dur en 15
jours chez moi tout seul avec mes
enfants et ma femme et c'était un vrai
bonheur c'était comme si j'avais très
envie de le faire mais je l'aurais
jamais fait tout seul en fait parce que
j'avais des enfants qui étaient en
primaire
et donc ça a été assez facile en fait de
puiser dans ce que je voyais chez eux
j'ai choisi le thème de l'école
naturellement parce que je suis pas en
délai c'est une école qui est pleine de
problèmes et qui est pleine de super
trucs donc j'avais plein de trucs à dire
et ça m'a emballé de de le faire puis
j'aime bien le côté la musique à la
maison en famille j'aime bien cette idée
et là le fait de faire un morceau par
jour tous les jours je devais faire un
morceau je lui ai envoyé le soir
très agréable quoi je crois que c'est un
des albums que j'ai fait pour lequel
j'ai pris j'ai pris le plus de plaisir
incroyables de trucs incroyable
et des hélicoptères les bottes de
Gulliver la maîtresse ton colère
tout le monde participe à chanter tout
le monde a donné son avis des quand je
séchais un peu je me faisais aidé par
mes gosses qui me donnaient des idées de
thème ou des idées puis c'est surtout
leur vie comme
ce que j'observais chez eux qui me
donnait vraiment la matière quoi et ça
s'entend sûrement que c'est bricoler à
la maison quoi c'est qu'il y a des
morceaux on entend le chat des morceaux
en autant la vaisselle
voilà
un Mexico
en bambara c'est compliqué année
soukoumen le matin et le midi c'est
Annick clé en Chine c'est
musicales moi je pioche de toute façon
prendre n'importe quel style de musique
que j'ai pu je me j'ai plus un style de
musique particulier quoi ça va du jazz
au reggae
là j'avais quand même l'idée d'une école
à la ville tu vois mais moi une école à
la Cité presque
une école où il y a beaucoup de couleurs
beaucoup d'origine
où il y a beaucoup d'enjeux aussi
du ketchup
quand tu parles à un enfant tu parles
pas un enfant de la même manière que tu
parles un adulte c'est sûr mais tu es
pas obligé non plus de te
diminuer ou t'as moins dur la moindre
rire ton propos quoi tu peux être
tu peux être un peu Provo tu peux les
enfants comprennent beaucoup de choses
en fait puis j'ai découvert après au fur
et à mesure en jouant le truc en jouant
les morceaux qui en effet ils comprenait
très bien même quand il y avait des
trucs un petit peu tordus comprenait
juste
mon tabouret c'est à moi c'est mon
secret sur les bancs de l'école
je pourrais en faire mon métier
vendeur de crottes de nez je passerai
tous les records je m'achèterai un soir
en or tu étais invité à La Verrière pour
faire un concert et
en parallèle il y avait des ateliers
dans une école l'école du parc avec une
classe de CM1 et du coup ils viennent
sur scène ils viennent terminer le
spectacle c'est un vrai bonheur vraiment
ils sont tous la paix ils sont tous
rigolos
ils sont à fond quoi
j'ai sauté dans le grand bain à la
on se transforme en requin l'eau ça nous
fait même pas peur quand on arrive nous
c'est l'eau qui a peur
on tourne beaucoup le spectacle pour les
spectacles au fond de la classe partout
en France on a bougé aussi à l'étranger
donc on est trois sur scène il y a un
beatboxer et un subasophoniste un énorme
tuyau pour faire les basses moi je fais
en parallèle un spectacle pour j'aime
pas dire spectacle pour adultes on dire
un truc pornographique c'est bien mais
pour tout le monde quoi de toute façon
même le truc pour les enfants c'est un
truc pour tout le monde pour moi et je
prépare un deuxième disque aussi pour
les petits qui parlera
des pays du monde des langues
des musiques du monde c'est un petit
Jules Verne de banlieue quoi tu vois qui
avait jamais quitté son quartier et qui
quand même voyage grâce aux gens qui
sont là
ah oui oui oui oui c'est nouveau sujet
de la rédaction c'est vrai je n'ai pas
dimanche à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
l'équipe de France est en finale au
terme d'une compétition de trois jours 8
équipes nationales se sont affrontés
pour le tout premier titre européen de
l'histoire du beatbox car il ne s'agit
pas ici de sport mais de musique
après avoir vaincu sous forme de Battle
musical la Russie et l'Espagne et 4
membres de l'équipe de France se
préparent pour la grande finale puisque
la compète est à la fois en solo en
équipe on a chacun notre secret en solo
et voilà et pour l'équipe on a on a
vraiment mis en place toutes nos idées
et on a tous notre spécialité en solo
après en équipe on essaie de rassembler
un peu nos forces voilà et puis voilà la
technique sont la France c'est la
technique la France la technique et puis
la diversité des le flots et le flow le
groove le groove le flow tout le hip-hop
cette discipline musicale qui consiste à
interpréter vocalement des sons et des
rythmes a pris ses sources dans le skate
des jazzman puis s'est développé avec le
hip-hop je suis impressionné par le
niveau par les performances et aussi par
l'évolution qui a eu par rapport au fait
au beatboxing parce que avant c'était la
reproduction des instruments qui avaient
comme la batterie quand la guitare comme
le scratch et puis au fur et à mesure
ils ont ils se sont appropriés tous les
styles comme l'électro comme le dub
comme tout ça donc c'est on a un panel
qui est vraiment important
sur le podium du premier championnat
européen de beatbox l'Allemagne s'est
imposé la France et deuxième
et encore quelques dates à noter avant
de changer la chaîne du vélo le 28 mai
le 21e cabaret politique se tiendra à la
ferme de Bel et bague Liancourt sur le
thème résistance le 31 mai les offrits
maracas seront en concert au scarabée à
la verrière et du 31 mai au 2 juin après
le présentera sa nouvelle pièce
chorégraphique intitulée Les nuits au
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines des
dates que vous pouvez retrouver ainsi
que l'ensemble de la programmation des
salles 50 images sur le kiosque sur
Internet aux adresses qui s'affichent là
non là ici voilà bon en tout cas tous
les mardis un concours et vous pouvez
gagner des places et c'est aussi là